risa Sean O'Brien thank you sir
basketball is a game of self-expression
NBA superstars constantly amaze me with
their Flair both on and off the court
I'll check out that outfit and you know
what NBA Live 16 is rooted in self
expression this comes to life in both
how you look and how you play so that
your entire in-game journey is all about
you and it's made possible through a
feature set requested by basketball
video game players because we make it a
priority to listen to you and what you
see today is a direct result of that it
starts with self expression off the
court but the brand new app that
features our exclusive game face HD
scanning tech and i want to show you
just how easy to use and how good you're
going to look in game now we've got our
NBA live community manager the hoop god
here to help you come on up here hoop
God where are you there you are all
right ok I see uh Ella's been good to
you oh oh really light work all right
all right Oh God so let's show them how
to do this here you go here's the app
I'll hold your hat for you pause right
there so you can see he's trying to fill
his face in this circle right there
pressing the camera got that's right
slowly to the right back to the middle
and now to the left and that's it so
what's happening right now the rat app
is actually generating a skin it takes
about five seconds and it's gonna
generate a preview for us hope it's
ready here we go let's take a look damn
I look just like me there we go whoa
whoa whoa you're gonna fix the bald spot
though right oh yeah we'll take care of
that in Game don't worry about it we got
you NBA Live 16 hits the streets
September 29th and this app will be
available before the game launches so
get ready to get yourself fresh people
just like me no hope God all right who
God thanks for help all right
so in just a few minutes the HD scan
brings you to life in the game just like
the NBA stars who've got scanned himself
last week so we can all see what he
looks like in game pretty hot if you've
ever wanted to be in a video games trust
me game face HD is the easiest and best
way to get it done and you'll only find
it in NBA Live now once you're in game
you'll be able to express yourself any
way you choose as you progress you'll
use global XP earned from across the
entire game to up your swag and improve
your skill set now let's take a look at
self expression on the court we are
laser focus on giving you unparalleled
control in best-in-class animation
fidelity first we spent two years
building a physics-based player movement
system called live motion now using an
innovative approach to motion capture
we've literally created thousands of new
animations and paired with runtime
physics this results in contextual
free-flowing movement like what you'd
expect to see on the basketball court
now this dynamic nature of live motion
keeps you in control of your players
movement you won't feel like you're
stuck in a scripted animation this will
truly free your game second completely
rebuilt passing and catching systems
will allow you to distribute the ball
exactly when and where you want with
touch passing and dribble handoffs this
gives you never seen before options to
move the ball around the perimeter next
let's take a look at the pick-and-roll
it's the bread and butter of today's NBA
and in these situations NBA Live 16
gives you the type of control you've
been asking for screen and rescreen
choose whether the screener rolls pops
or slips now you can choose how you
defend it by showing trapping the ball
or even switching finally our players
have also told us that they want more
control when shooting the basketball
we've created a new shot system that
gives you full control to release the
ball when
you want so the longer you actually hold
a button press the later you'll release
give you complete control of your shot
in situations all over the court we've
never had this level of gameplay control
before so for those of you Eddie 3
please come by and check it out you
really have to feel it you know just how
much these new controls change the game
and later this summer we're going to be
revealing a new game mode unless you say
we're committed to delivering a reliable
and stable place to play basketball
online with your friends it's time to
rise together now let's take a look at
our trailer featuring footage captured
entirely from in-game